what's up
everyone bang bang lunch money time it's
friday
you know what that means friday means
you don't got to go to work
fridays you don't got to go to work you
ain't got to go to school just get your
ass on youtube and learn some stuff
today
while while she's trying to get rich
restaurants just trying to get our lunch
money right i'm here with a christmas
tree
no problem it's not a christmas tree
it's like santa claus
which you will understand while i'm
wearing this later in lunch money
okay don't forget that lunch money is
now sponsored by block five block fives
got an interest bearing account eight
point six percent ap why
your bank ain't paying you that so go
fix
that problem and go get a block by
account blockfy.com
slash pomp go do it no brainer
if you ain't got one you're just a fool
and we know that we don't like no fools
around here so get a blockfi account
blackfly.com
what's up hey what's up okay but
it's news time i'm hungry and you're
preventing me from eating right now
okay so paypal is said to be in talks
by crypto firms including bitco
according to bloomberg
um the news comes a day after the
payments giant
announced that it's entering the
cryptocurrency market bitco was the
first u.s crypto firm to secure broker
dealer approval
transfer agent registration and trust
company recognition allowing it to
provide custody and record keeping
services
so i will not comment away on
the paypal and bitcoin situation but i
will comment
on interesting dwight m a and
consolidation
of course this is going to happen if
you're a legacy player you got to get up
to speed it's not just a tech thing you
can't just
build technology and then you're ready
to go you got to have the knowledge
think for yourself you got to have the
crypto knowledge and if you don't have
people who have that knowledge you're
out of luck
so the fastest way to get the knowledge
the tech and the experience
and expertise is to go buy companies
okay go on and so that's probably what's
going to happen with a lot of these
incumbents they're going to be buying
exchanges and be buying custodians from
you buying all this stuff
so do you think that this is not the
last of mna and crypto we'll see in the
near future do we think
other firms traditionally starting
getting started
just starting just getting started
whatever all right
ready yes in a blow to uber and lyft to
california appeals court said thursday
thursday that the companies must
reclassify their drivers as employees
rather than independent contractors
affirming an earlier court decision it's
been a
long fight along the road you don't
think so
nope why not my guess is that they're
going to end up not being classified as
employees
they will not end up being classified as
employees
that's that's my uh guess yeah is we're
going to actually get
they're not going to be contractors
they're not going to be employees
they're going to be gig workers a third
one's going to emerge because you can't
you just can't run that business
uh with them as employees so and that's
not to say that they shouldn't get
benefits and do all the things that they
need because they are working they are
doing that stuff
but it's just we need a third group so
if uber and lyft are willing to create a
third group for these people
how does that affect the legal
proceedings well the
the law is always uh lags behind
innovation
so it's gonna take legislation probably
to change the law
uh and so they can try but more so
they're gonna have to lobby to get the
law changed
oh interesting all right this week you
see that do you see that yawn i just did
that was kind of undercover
because somebody slept all day but
somebody did not go ahead he came to
wake me up and i continued sleeping
sorry three times okay not three times
go ahead come on
i'm a dangerous sleeper out here okay
this week
tesla began pushing its full
self-driving update to a select group of
customers
and the first reactions are now
beginning to roll in the software which
enables drivers to use many of
autopilot's advanced driver assist
features on local non-highway streets
is still in beta as such it requires
constant monitoring while in operation
or as tesla warns and its introductory
introductory language
it may do the wrong thing at the worst
time
this is wild so they're sending updates
to people's cars
over the air yes one of the innovations
go ahead they're like air dropping
some auto self-driving updates the
software
yeah okay they're updating the software
but it used to be that the self-driving
feature the autopilot feature
you turned it on the highway and i mean
on the highway it's like not that hard
because
there's lines on the road right there's
usually everyone's moving at the similar
speed
you don't have to deal with starting and
stopping at intersections you have to
deal with pedestrians like
it's a much easier kind of technology
problem to solve it's still
hard but but it's easier than let's say
city driving
right imagine driving in new york city
versus on a highway in you know kentucky
man new york city will be the ultimate
test for these self-driving cars
well what is now happening is they've
got this full self-driving feature and
so now it can do non-highway roads
supposedly can do cities like this gonna
get pretty crazy here
but you have to sit there and you're
supposed to be paying attention but like
humans are idiots
how many humans are like i got
self-driving on let me just play on
twitter
no no no i hope that's not a lot of
people i'd be like
no that's exactly what's about to happen
early reactions to the software updates
range from that was a little scary to
full-throated enthusiasm for ceo
elon musk's willingness to let his
customers beta test features that aren't
ready for wide release
so this is actually really interesting
because what car company
lets its drivers test the beta
like that well he needs data that's
right that's the whole thing is so how
do you get data as fast as possible
you put it in in the cars and the cars
are all driving around so you can get as
much data as possible like the amount of
data
that tesla has in improving their
self-driving versus google
is not even close because google has
their own cars that are going around
getting that information whereas tesla
has all our customers gathering it for
them
and so same thing here is he's going to
get a bunch of data
very quickly by letting the customers do
it but
it's also dangerous and so like you know
if it was dangerous like hey drink this
you may get sick that's one thing it's
another thing if you're like hey
by the way your car is going to drive
itself and it may crash and so
people are basically having to opt into
this update from what i understand
so let me ask you this because tesla has
so much data on its drivers
do you think for this beta program it
picked like the safest most responsible
drivers that
you know the data tells them that is a
good question i don't know
but the other thing that they're doing
is they are
presenting the information a really
interesting way i saw a video i think
was yesterday
uh or today i can't remember but
basically they're showing you what the
like self-driving technology sees so the
computer doesn't see like my face
this computer basically is doing like
object uh recognition
it's doing uh lidar right it's kind of
using all these different technologies
and the way that the computer actually
sees
what's going on and can understand it is
being presented to the driver
my guess is that's to convince the
driver like hey there's like
really complex stuff going on right now
pay attention rather than
just be like hey here's a movie to watch
yeah all right next what's up all right
so this is super interesting actually
walmart is suing the federal government
in an attempt to strike a preemptive
blow against what it
what it said is an impending opioid
related civil lawsuit
from the justice department walmart's
saying that the justice department and
drug enforcement administration's
administration are seeking to scapegoat
the company for the federal government's
own regulatory enforcement shortcomings
in combating the opioid crisis
walmart said the government is seeking
steep financial penalties against the
retailer
for allegedly contributing to the opioid
crisis by filling questionable
prescriptions
but walmart's point is these are
prescriptions filled by our pharmacists
legally that were given by the doctors
like the pharmacist
although there are some pharmacists who
refuse to fill the subscription
prescriptions but
anyway well hold on go on so this is a
this is super complex you guys already
heard my thoughts about the opioid
crisis and the scumbag sacklers but i'm
not going to go there
right uh in words of uh somebody else no
disrespect
but scumbag sacklers uh but in this
situation what i do think
is really important is uh
there is a doctor that gives the
prescription right
to the patient the patient then takes it
to the pharmacy and says hey fulfill
this
the pharmacist has ethical standards
that they have to that's
true uh to fulfill but how do they know
hold on
at the same time they can hide behind
the fact like
a doctor gave this prescription somebody
brought it in i filled it
so what ends up happening here is this
is not a criminal suit this is a civil
suit
and what they're basically exclaiming is
that the pharmacists were doing this
but they should have known that there
were red flags they basically ignored
the red flags
so somebody comes in you know once a
week with
uh oxycontin prescriptions like
hey sure you can say i legally just
filled with the doctor said
or you can again not be an [ __ ] and
you can say
oh maybe this person's a drug addict and
we shouldn't be giving them more drugs
like that would be a shocking thing it's
like doing the right thing so i'm
guessing the pharmacists do have that
power because we watched a documentary
on netflix one time about the opioid
crisis and there was this pharmacist in
a small town
and he kept refusing to fill these
prescriptions because he
knew very well what was going on but
then the people would just go to another
pharmacy
that's fine but look it's a balance and
there's no black or white solution here
and also
there's uh it's hard for me to
understand
being in that pharmacist chair and
having to deal with the balance between
like
what if i'm wrong and this person
actually is in pain and needs this
what if they're actually abusing it
right like all these different things
uh that go through somebody's head but
at the end of the day
come on let's get some common sense here
i get it
i'm a capitalist just like everybody
else but maybe we shouldn't be giving
people oxycontin
every single week but that might be a
little much
obviously let's go next and i also think
that walmart won't get uh
won't get found guilty go ahead no
they're not even but they they haven't
even been accused of anything this is no
they are accused they
the government has not alleged that the
company was filling ultra prescriptions
or that
pharmacist had inappropriate
relationships with patients or doctors
it's just trying to pre like it's trying
to no no
those are three different things so the
government hasn't alleged that they
filled altered prescriptions and they're
not alleging that they had inappropriate
relationships with the patients or the
doctors
but what they are alleging is that the
pharmacist
filled valid prescriptions but they
should have
known that they that that was unethical
well it says the
walmart's lawsuit is an unusual and
aggressive tactic for a company in high
stakes talks with the department
it suit won't necessarily head off any
justice department action
but a court ruling embracing the
company's view if the law could give it
a weapon against any government
people won't like to hear this but
walmart's negotiating right now
probably that's what they're doing
they're posturing it's a negotiation
coca-cola is speaking of drugs
coca-cola is saying goodbye to 200
brands or half of its portfolio
the beverage giant had already announced
that it would discontinue some beloved
if outdated drinks like
tab ziko thursday was the first time the
company said it would get rid of
200 of them and uh you know
they didn't give specific names that
will get axed but they're
they're in the hydration category with
dasani powerade vitamin water oh no
vitamin
water and ziko and other brands will
likely see more cuts
oh man vitamin water i always thought
that i should get in the water game
everybody needs some water drink up oh
wait can i can i show that twitter
account
no it's like drink some water hose i
think it's what it's called
yeah it's something like that or just
add drink water or something and it's
always tweeting it just
periodically throughout the day to say
drink water okay good
you shouldn't drink water but in like
funny ways like a funny story
yeah um one time so the coca-cola museum
is in atlanta
and one time i went with my dad evo who
has been on this show before
and we all went uh and then there's like
a whole
uh room where you can try different coke
products from all over the country
and there's one that's like notoriously
really really bad
so i was like dad dad come try this one
and like everybody tries and they're
really like oh and he's like
this is very good and then we're like
this is the worst one he's like oh oh
yeah no this is very bad very bad
and then we all went our separate ways
and i saw him out of the corner of my
eye
had gone back to that machine and
refilled his little cup with that one
and he was like enjoying it
because he's got a strong stomach don't
be letting anybody make fun of you
it was funny sorry santa claus over here
santa claus is our next topic
sorry evo's got a strong stomach santa's
all right hold on because this isn't
loading and i don't know why
because santa claus isn't real santa
claus kid show kid show just kidding the
idea
is that santa claus is not coming to
macy's this year
isn't that sad so macy's santa
macy said santa claus will be getting uh
to go to its flagship new york store
this year due to coronavirus
interrupting a holiday tradition started
nearly 160 years ago
he gets paid bank i saw somewhere hold
on
uh so santa's not coming to macy's he's
not i'll come to
macy's call me call me i'll come you
give me the gifts i'll hand them out
no but the idea we can give bitcoin to
all the kids teach them about a little
monetary policy
macy's sandy but you ain't calling me
santa claus we're gonna come with a
better name than that
salary i i just read somewhere
no i said i thought it was like 300k oh
for 300k
macy's we can talk i'll do it for 250.
no problem but i already have the outfit
so nobody's thinking you're santa you
just said i was santa in the intro
no i see you look at christmas trees
okay ready roll back the tape from my
joke no
yeah my friend denied that he was a
ghost but i knew he was lying
why why because i could see right
through him
i knew we were gonna do that it's not
funny it was a joke guys
it was funny guys i have a confession to
make
what paulina is leaving me for a week
it don't be telling people for a whole
week i'm gonna be on my own
and she gave me a talk yesterday and she
said are you sure you're gonna be okay
do you know how to make
food do you know where the water is she
even asked me if i would be able to find
soap for my shower if i run out of soap
that's that's what she thinks about me
she thinks that like literally
she would come back after a week and i
would just be dying of malnutrition on
the ground and
smelling because i haven't showered in a
week my biggest one
wrong am i not my biggest worry is that
he won't eat what's in the fridge
instead he'll order dominoes every
single day and then i'll return and i'll
be like what happened here
should i order dominoes every day for a
week
no hide in your hoodie okay
bye guys bang bang
hope you guys enjoyed this episode of
lunch money as much as we did
and don't forget lunch money is now
sponsored by block five so go check them
out there's a link in the description
that you can click on
i'm an investor a user and a huge fan
what you're a bigger fan of block five
than you are of me
block fly's my second favorite thing in
the world behind polina they've got
three products
they can give you a us dollar loan you
can earn up to eight point six percent
interest on an interest bearing account
or you can buy and sell cryptocurrencies
on their crypto exchange
i personally use the interest bearing
account there's not very many places
where you'll find
up to eight point six percent interest
on a deposit in an interest bearing
account
go do your own research there's risk
associated but eight point six percent
is pretty compelling
so click on the link in the description
say thanks to the folks at blockfly
subscribe to our channel like the video
annoy pulling in the comments
and we'll see you guys tomorrow and be
kind to your friends